good morning my name is counselor truly
good in and I'm the chairman of the
licensing subcommittee for today's
hearing the emergency evacuation will be
read out first should we be required to
evacuate the building would you please
leave the building via the nearest
available exit to the chamber our
assembly point will be at the public
carpark at the side of the Civic Suites
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by council staff
please note that this meeting will be
audio recorded
please can everyone use their
microphones when speaking and ensure
that their mobile phones are switched
off or on silent the purpose of this
hearing is to consider an application
for a temporary event notice for two
events to be held on the 26th through to
the 28th of June 2019 at heteros stables
Burlington Gardens halbridge Essex ss5
6b e submitted by the applicant Nicholas
Smith you will all have an opportunity
to speak and ask questions please only
speak when it is your turn I will ask
all parties to formally identify
themselves please can the council's
licensing officer introduce herself
good morning Jen Fowler principal
licensing officer Roger Council could
the applicant and applicants
representative introduce themselves
and do you propose to call any witnesses
okay thank you
as this is an application for temporary
events notice rather than a license the
only interested part is permitted to
make representations are the police and
the Environmental Health Department of
the council in their role as responsible
authorities Essex Police have submitted
an objection does the responsible
Authority wish to speak from please
could you introduce yourself they become
represented Essex place to my left is it
mr. Gordon Ashford also represent a
sixth place and to my left of the left
of him he's clearly drying from Essex
place as well and we would like to make
some representations today thank you
the Environmental Health Department have
submitted an objection does the
responsibility of all authority wish to
speak if you do please can you introduce
yourself
good morning is chiffon Sheraton
environment health senior environmental
health take the officer and yes would
like to make representations today
thank you have all parties received the
agenda and report for today's hearing
are there any questions at this stage
the hearing will follow the procedure
set out on pages three point one to
three point three on the agenda
just to keep you informed the 15 minutes
permitted for any responsible an
authority to present their submissions
and 15 minutes permitted for the
applicants to present their submissions
all parties that make submissions at the
hearing will also be given two minutes
at the end of the hearing to make a
closing statement
these times may only be extended with
the permission of the subcommittee
licensing officer would you like to
introduce your application please
this report introduces an application
for the grant of a temporary event
notice under Section 100 of the
licensing Act 2003 during the
consultation period of Jackson's were
received from the police and
Environmental Health regarding the
planned events on the 3rd of June 2019
the licensing department wrote to the
venue informing the lands owner that the
department was made aware of unlicensed
After Prom parties planned for hetero
stables for Swain's school of its
whymark school on the 26th 27th of June
2019 and enclosed forms for a temporary
event notice and in event management
plan template on the 10th of June 2019 a
temporary event notice was received from
Nicholas Smith the licensure activities
for the provision the licensure
activities are for the provision of
regulated entertainment recorded music
and late-night refreshment the maximum
number of people attending each event is
expected to be a hundred but as the
events I'll pay on the door the maximum
numbers are unknown the times requested
for each event are 2300 hours
203 hundred hours this venue is disabled
and fields in an unmade singletrack Road
off lower road whole bridge the police
served an objection for the proposed
events under the ten on the grounds that
the event will undermine the following
licensing objectives crime and disorder
of public nuisance Public Safety and the
protection of children from
environment health have also served an
objection on the grounds that the events
will undermine the public nuisance
objective on the 13th of June 2019 Valen
request from the licensing department
and event management plan was submitted
by Nicholas Smith outlining the safety
plans for the event this plan has been
sent to the Safety Advisory Group for
comments appendix G is a response from
the Health and Safety Officer as a
member of the Safety Advisory Group
regarding the event management plan for
the after proms
events all parties involved up in server
the relevant notices and documentation
an equality impact assessment has been
completed and found there to be no
impacts either positive or negative on
protected groups as defined in the
Equality Act of 2010 the following
options are available to members to
determine that the events would
undermine the licensing objective and
server council motives to allow the
licensable activities to go ahead as
stated in the notice or subject to
paragraph 1113 of the license in act
2000 of three hearings regulations 2005
to adjourn the hearing to a specified
day or arrange for a hearing to be held
on specified additional dates where
members consider this to be necessary
for the consideration of any
representations or notice made by the
party the recommendation it is proposed
that the subcommittee resolves to
determine the notice having considered
all representations made at the hearing
thank you
you have any questions miss my man Thank
You chef
do any of the parties require
clarification from the licensing officer
at this point
Essex place would you like to make your
representation Thank You chair yes
obviously what we look here today is a
look about the police representations
about the proposed of in and its impact
on the wider community and the impact
and effect it has on young people I'll
be referring to appendix D which is in
your packs which is our report and why
we want why we're here today because the
serious concerns we have about the event
and the undermining of the fall items
and objectives which are namely crime
disorder public nuisance prevention of
children from harm and Public Safety and
those parts um within your packs there
within item four pendeks one is the
Flyers circular which was one party I'll
refer to that it's begin with it if
you're okay with that can I just confirm
that you've looked at the papers for me
and my part and you're happy with that
thank you
and the flyer itself is obviously as a
charge of twenty five pound per person
so we're looking at a profit-making
event here and if you looking at numbers
of a hundred persons two and a half
thousand pound and I five thousand
pounds over the two nines
however the concerning things around the
the floor itself is some of the middle
paragraphs where we talked about where
you must have a consent letter to be
able to drink alcohol and attend the
after party the after the the consent
letter is in form of in the flyer but it
also mentions about allowing alcohol
within the site and children were
allowed to drink within the actual
society itself so there are concerns
from us from our perspective around
their children bring in a call to the
source accreting our Co around the site
all coming to the air the event actually
having consumed some echo in the first
place and the if you if you'll be bear
with me I'll just go through what our
the location of the event in a bit more
detail I'm not sure if you're familiar
with that but H wrote stay with farms
situation off a small single track lane
which docked legs into some fields and
some stables into bones and Gardens the
area is quite remote I would suggest
it's poorly lit there are a few
residents around around the area but the
traffic can only go one way in and one
way out unless you allow each vehicle to
pass so it is a very difficult location
to to actually be at the location itself
is in a remote I would say a remote part
of the era of help with yourself based
off lower road I'll go through the crime
of disorder gets at least a few happy to
do so but we're concerns are is that 15
16 year-old children will like to
consume alcohol before they've gone to
the event they have been at this school
I think there's a prom event at the
school beforehand and they're gonna make
their way to this event quite late at
night the the event is for over hundred
children although we can't confirm one
hundred children there may be more than
that because of social media nowadays
may increase that figure somewhat and
the the flyer actually itself betrays
the true intentions of the organisers
which to allow an event in a field with
over 100 children in the early hours of
the morning to be partying and likely to
be drinking alcohol or having drunk
alcohol in the first place there are
other concerns what we have around the
crime disorder as well and it's
certainly there's there's a mention of
drug searching going on but drugs
searching is very difficult to
fine nowadays on people with the the
actual drugs could be secreted in small
small parts of the the the clothing and
it have to be a very thorough search in
order to identify any so any any drugs
itself also there's concern there date
because there's potentially around young
people who carry sharp instruments I'm
not saying the children gonna have shop
instance but it's likely that there's
some could have so there is a danger
there and concern for us around the
crime and disorder of that location
obviously the public nuisance aspect is
the the actual rival and the exit of the
young people and there's no plan around
how the children are going to go home
and it suggests that some of the parents
will collect the young people around
three o'clock in the morning that can't
be confirmed and they can't always be a
confirmation from the parents will
actually turn out at that time I like to
collect their children so what we're
expecting is that that last large groups
of children will be walking down these
unlit roads to a main road having
possibly intoxicated making their way
home through lower road and parts of
hull breach and raelia itself which is a
real concern and could will lead to
public nuisance and disorder within
their facility Public Safety we've
mentioned around the venue itself that
the lighting and the countryside
location and there is a concern around
children being in the field and missing
within that locality the increased
number of vehicles we've been up and
down that road I'm familiar Central
Avenue itself is a very very poor Road
it's a very undulating road with deep
deep deep holding so there's going to be
a fair bit of traffic if the parents are
going to take them to that location if
children do decide to walk to the
location there's quite a danger for them
because of the unlit and come
along those very narrow lines from from
the children's harm perspective we feel
there's the Abney event it's been
advertised with children were exposed to
alcohol possibly other drugs and other
how that harm could be caused the fly
makes it abundantly clear that so the
children will will get there's an
expectation that we could get drunk and
this will expose the children to
physical harm there's no medical
treatment and they could well be that we
have to call emergency services in order
to rescue all the young children to
hospitals the site itself is insecure so
it's possible that some people could
enter the the land itself through
different hedgerows there's no salt I
was saying good fainting around there
the printer is not a secure site so it's
possible excuse me
possible that so other children could
enter the site also true alcohol around
the site itself beforehand there's a
real concern from Essex police around
the missing persons in the area although
they're tagged and when they go in with
wristbands we could not confirm that
that will be done in a concise way and
we can't be sure what will happen to the
young persons as they leave or if they
haven't left the premises we've got a an
area of very much of rural area which
would be very difficult to track and
trace a missing person within that
facility so there are our main concerns
under the under these under the
licensing act and what I would like you
to consider obviously is that the Essex
Police believe that the application in
its current state should be rejected in
full because of the factors any now in
our paper we've mentioned a number of
conditions which are taken from the
guidance especially a condition at the
free point two of your papers that you
should be mindful that venues does not
have
benefit of a premises license and should
the should the subcommittee be minded to
allow the event to go ahead as he's
pleased Rogers members the attention of
paragraph seven point four in 7.8 of the
guidance this is a free point to of your
obvious appendix D and it dictates that
the lightest Pro cannot impose
conditions on the event subject so this
ten no matter what undertakings are
given by the applicant so you can't
actually can't actually do anything here
stay in post conditions to make this
thing as a safer event so they could
they're unenforceable we just like to
draw that to your attention overall we
obviously have concerns around public
safety which will be draw your attention
to paragraph 2.7 of the guidance and
that that includes around the physical
safety and Prevention of accidents and
immediate harm from the consumption of
alcohol and in paragraph 2.8 the
guidance matters that should be
considered a relations but these include
fire safety and other matters which I'm
sure my other colleagues will bring up
later so we have real concerns about the
event in in all obviously there is a the
main concern overall there there's a
protection of children from harm they're
a young young young group of people and
they will be unaccompanied at the time
and could be exposed to some pretty
difficult situations so I draw your
attentions to paragraph three point
three point eight which talks about the
licensing authority should give
considerable weight of to represent some
children for child protection matters
where a responsible authority presents
for there's evidence to the local
authority linking specific premises with
harm to children this evidence should be
considered and the licensing authority
should also consider what action is
appropriate to ensure this slice and
ejector isn't effectively enforce Essex
Police considers of the authority in
this case permit only can only ensure
effective enforcement by rejecting the
temporary event notice thank you
thank you
I have no questions at present Thank You
chairman
okay I've got a question around the
fencing around the paddock and stables
you said it wasn't
yeah it could be great can you elaborate
a little bit more on that for my
organization so the the pensions at
hydro or anything the actual there's a
hydro around the field which can there
are access points for out and you have a
stables it's selfish but I think it's
probably for about five or six horses
and a small stable area but the field
itself isn't a secure either called a
secure field with proper fencing is a
hedgerow itself as it would fit a rural
setting and what about these is there
any decent gates between the stables and
the field or well there are dates but
they are just prevent horses from from
from accessing and xìng xìng the arrow
itself so it's easy to climb thank you
[Music]
Thank You chairman um a couple of
questions from our police colleagues
please and firstly bearing in mind that
this event is for children we must take
that into account the SI a licensed
staff do you know have they enhanced DPS
chicks and will they have firm child
protection policy and procedures in
place I'm talking enhanced if I may
there's no suggestion that isn't
hostages checks if this was I premises
were premises licensed ahead and
writings in it
Essex police would have
rejects the applications that were
unless dps in heart statistics would put
in so as general rule if you have might
have told other things that can ever
event for children on their licensee at
every corner that one that there's
hearts T this chip start that is an
appropriate ratio of female and now a
security staff not just one female and
that's because obviously if you're gonna
search for drugs etc you need something
wooden house TBS checks to actually
search potentially intimately in the
broad why except particularly is where a
young women tend to excrete drugs and in
the end if aligned so we would use the
asked for that as a requirement for a
premises Isis this is a temporary event
no it's Nev already heard the economy
post conditional may that is one of the
reasons why we're so concerned about
this have been being as it is take the
place after given the book at night into
three o'clock the following morning and
children have been a out enjoying their
self and it's the attraction of this
opinion thank you him just a follow-up
question on that one and these are
children what is the ratio for an event
of a hundred children do you know that
the organizers a say if it was a
premises license they would probably
bring those shows of staff required to
children for those events this is a
temporary event notice it standard
African angry County for so many things
all live conditions because it's a
template event notice thank you couple
more questions I'm looking at the flyer
that you drew our attention to it does
say on there
the owner accepts no responsibility for
loss damages illness to you your
personal belongings you accept this when
you sign the disclaimer now you're
referring in there to the actor 1957 I
think it is landowners act yes yes then
x axis off-course Liability Act and
unfair contracts registration so you
cannot put into a contract to remove
your liability for something anymore
you've got an opportunity for so they
would be liable for anything is that
what you're saying they would be whether
the insurance covers that there's
another issue these offseason they
concerned potentially go it's not the
reasons what we want justice
thank you and 2.5 just why we own it
there may be more questions I'm sorry
2.5 around drugs now my understanding is
from previous experience that a drug
safe would be provided prior premises my
own instinct is I'm not overly happy
that they would be burned there's no
record no indication of how this would
be recorded under this use of drugs
things cool things to be in possession
of drugs until you rendered them some
später a police officer there's no in
the EMP that's Justin they're gonna burn
the drugs that she doesn't comply with
the Act because you can only season keep
drugs and premises until you hand them
over to police constable hints for I
lost its hinges tend to have tub safes
otherwise still in the drugs and it is a
concern also that these sort of events
with drugs the seasons same festivals
and that often the drugs are
recirculated or saw I I appreciate that
and obviously we don't know that and
you're assuming that but the fact that a
drug safe should be provided that's good
practice and not burning them that's the
main issue here yes yes thank you
you've clarified by self is quite hot
hard question is when I've got laughter
coming from in front of me from me and
representatives colleagues of
indiscretion decorum could be requested
Thank You Gemma and that's all for now
thank you
just a reminder that it is a formal
hearing so if we could have that decorum
in the you'll get your chance to have
your say
do you have any questions for the place
in response to what you've just heard
I feel rude because I'm not actually
fine but I just wanted to ask and we
would obviously we arranged this as a
private party and then the comments came
up about the concerns that the the
police had and we've addressed them all
alcohol won't be allowed we've notified
everybody that know-how is allowed now
and all children have to be collected
obviously take torches to go down the
roads could you I don't give a question
yet they're actually saying that is one
way through the chair sorry the they're
saying the road is one way it's not
there's you come in one way you go
around in a big circle you go hit the
other way thank you
do you have any other questions and you
sound about the hedges and the gates
they keep our horses safe horses are a
liberal question so well that basically
why do you think that they're hedges and
the gates are not safe to keep children
in then they keep horses in thank you
inherently we believe it's totally
unsafe we've been aimed the flag does
mean to what this could be tolerate if
it hadn't been for the council
intervening this event would have been
taking place without any application
whatsoever which demonstrates that the
applicant has no knowledge of the nicest
objectives and skin understanding in the
pair to actually protect the children at
that time and night from the potential
threat thank you
environmental health would you like to
present
the
also anointed riding friends sort of
dispersed
and also children
thank you do you have any questions do
you have any questions for environmental
health your second question
yep you're saying that if it's a party
there's going to be a disturbance does
that mean nobody in Holdrege can have
parties
and
lovely
thank you do you have any more questions
okay
would the applicants like to make a
presentation we have 15 minutes
[Music]
hello my name is Nikki and I'm just a
normal mum like any other normal mums
and I just want wanted the kids to be
safe my two friends Beverley and Lindsey
bypass me if I could and lo at the back
asked me if we could do something for
the kids for their after pie and I said
yeah we'll try and do something which is
what I've tried to do I'm not out to
break any laws or put the kids in danger
I'm just a normal everyday mum I have
tried my best to oppose all these part I
am dyslexic so I do find paperwork hard
but I have tried my best to fill out all
these forms and keep the kids safe the
fields van hydro sorry the field and
hedgerow are Hawthorne bushes there is
no way anyone could get into that field
other than through the main gate where
the kids come fro the horses are a
hundred and ten percent safe they are my
liveries I would not put the horses in
any danger at all they cannot be
accessed at all we are sitting right
outside their gate that go to their yard
no one can go into them horses they put
up with fireworks when people have
massive fireworks displays it and it
doesn't affect him they do not mind the
music there is one other gate at the top
of the field which I have stated on my
plan that if there was a fire the
children would be escorted up the middle
of the line to the end field I asked for
the consent letters so if there is any
problems I can bring their parents
straight away and they can come and pick
him up so if there is any doubt of
anything all the children would be
counted in and then when we got to the
top if there was a fire or any incident
I'd count them again they literally
cannot get the area that is fenced in is
electric fence but it's obviously not on
for the night there is six bouncers
there is always one at the gate of B bus
once the children are in partying and
the rest are all in walking around the
children making sure they're all
safe making sure that no one's getting
out of hand
or then I've done I've done a few after
parties for my kids when they've left
school and the kids are always
impeccably behaved they cannot get out
of that fenced area there is people
walking man their areas all the time so
even though it's a five acre field they
cannot get to the rest of the field
they are looked at on monitored all the
time I have got the kids best interest
at heart all I want them to do is have a
good night with all their mates for
their last for the last night it's four
hours I've lived up Central Avenue for
32 years I know all my neighbors
personally and I have spoken tomorrow
not one of them Minds me doing the
partay they're not worried about the
music I don't have what you call I call
it the boom boom boom music that they
have raves they have normal dance music
I watched the music level all the time
if I think it's getting too loud we turn
it down my DJ is really good we turn all
the music the music starts getting
slowed down about half toe so then this
they're not as hyped up when they go
home but if I've got to get all the kids
picked up they have to all be picked up
that's fine
we've all we've both spoke and we've
said what if the kids have to be pizza
they have to be picked up if there's no
alcohol there's no alcohol we check for
drugs if there's any drugs found which I
never have if there's any drugs found
I've got a steel box which I keep and
then the next morning they're dropped
off at Raley police station if I have to
I've never had to ever and Bev's
daughter Maddie she's like she's leaving
lose son Archie it was his partay I
don't in tempo in any children in danger
at all and I'm trying my best so they
can all just have a good time and fun as
for the point about toilets that were
made in this event plan
I was on the under set I've got two
toilets I can't have more but I was
under the understanding it's one toilet
150 girls one toilet pour 450 well I'm
not gonna have that many kids it's not a
major event it's just a swine and a Fitz
after-party and yes I understand they're
only 15 16 but where where the kids
gonna go otherwise they're not go about
a monitor room if they're in the parks
or doing whatever I'm just trying to
make them so they've got somewhere to go
where they can be safe and enjoy
themselves okay thank you
I've been asked to address the issues
raised by the environment health and the
Essex Police in relation to the
celebration of achievement for the young
people finishing their education from
Swain school prior to these concerns
being raised a number of risk
assessments have been made and they're
here for your perusal the key issues
raised are environmental health funding
for children having accidents on route
home but as we've said we've addressed
that we would tell all parents to
collect their children Essex Police have
raised concerns about girls being
checked when they come in and boys being
checked we have two ghosts two women and
is it forming yeah for Maine so both
girls and boys can be searched the
safety getting home and no alcohol will
all be addressed we can sort all that
out we will sort it out all parents have
been advised to collect the young people
from the event or to nominate a parent
to collect their child although mergency
numbers have been given and will be held
to reach young person it's not
impossible for a young person to hurt
themselves on the burger van Nicky's
doing food so basically if they were
drinking at least they were having
sanctuary but if they're not they've
still got food there so she's supplying
food as well as for the comment that you
know it's a making money
it really isn't by the time you've hired
a marque and hired staff and bought all
the food that she's proposed free of
charge to these children we're satisfied
that this will be safe and monitored
event for the young people
once a highlight to hold that the risks
to any young person would increase if
celebrations happened in isolation in
small groups of young people where there
is no oversight of responsible adults
and no identified safe area the lack of
a safe and identified area would
potentially increase the risk to the
young people and would clearly impact
any police response required as a parent
I'm keen you know that my daughter
along with all the other students at
Swain school and fit school
Skol have worked incredibly hard to
achieve their potential in the exam year
and more than deserve a chance to
celebrate their achievements and move on
an appositive to the next phase of their
lives I have over 40 emails here
supporting that this this party and
obviously you can see that people have
come to support as well we're all caring
concerned parents but we all understand
that our young people want to party with
their friends away from us and away from
their teachers I would say 99% of
teachers not only the young people on
this event to go ahead nikki is a
well-respected part of our community
that we all feel we can trust to keep
our children safe whilst having fun
she is organizing a party for our young
children and I think we should all and
that includes the police the
Environmental Health and us parents
should be grateful because without this
they are going to congregate everywhere
put in that the already overstretched
police resources to extremes and I for
one won't be happy if this happens and
the police don't keep my children safe
the organised event is a confined area
with more than enough adults to
supervise them with telephone numbers if
needed in emergency parents and young
people want to go and I truly can't
understand why you feel fit to cancel
this event we have support from
everybody and my took my daughter and
all the children really want this event
to go ahead thank you
okay um first om the African it's okay
if I call you Nikki and Nikki you said
them in your opening statement you
wanted kids to be safe and I don't think
there's anybody in this room it's not
singing from the same hymn sheet but we
have to look at it from a legal
perspective no just picking up on some
of the things that you've mentioned
about you will now arrange for the
children to be picked up in their
alcohol and don't ask the place just to
refer back to 3.2 in your conditions on
page four point nine of your report and
in layman's terms for everybody in the
room could you exactly go through that
part because I just entertain
late not officially or to sell alcohol
or to set up house only the Riddler any
the licensure activities need a license
or an authorization a license he's a
premises license or a club pension Isis
came into a working men's club et cetera
North was a shion's attempt Levin Marius
in law for appearances license and
applicants consider me a series of
conditions they want to put on their
license consistent to their operating
schedule and if one of the other
responsible authorities doesn't feel
that is sufficient they can make a
objection it goes through here and such
this and youth as licensing subcommittee
can put a list of conditions on that
license not legally enforceable and if
the conditions aren't
complied with criminal offenses are
committed to prevent notice you cannot
in house any conditions on the temporary
make noise and this attempt event those
relates to our premises that's got a
license so far as I pop open to 11
o'clock at night now I want it to carry
on to 1:00 in the morning you could
impose conditions to all the conditions
that counting on my license to live in a
clock lyrics Timbit wing living o'clock
and one o'clock on attempt prevent now
is you the subcommittee
cannot impose any conditions at all so
bias it the applicant from go ahead and
do whatever they want
they can given assurance to you now
there's no way from forcing assurance
thank you and there was just couple of
bits I want to point pick up on you
mentioned your countless children in and
if there was an emergency and I've
already noted that you said these
children can't get through the whole
form Bushies or gates
the exit for hundred children in a rush
in you'll be able to count them through
I have to say I've got huge concerns
because it's going to be dark you trying
to count hates in-between coming out of
the gate the paddocks I might have
walked off into the bushes so I have I
have got and I'm not sure whether one of
my police is going to pick up on it but
the consent letters being a parent I
know my son wrote consent letters which
I never saw inside them what guarantee
have you got that you've actually got
the parents consent and their exact
details
I'm being honest fish so you don't think
that would be a possibility I want to go
to the after-prom party mum no you're
grounded well yes you would
[ __ ] the old parents
so the parents have all got to collect
from I'll be honest a few the
disturbance doesn't concern me as much
it's around child safety but there is no
checking mechanism what if a child
hasn't disclosed disability they have a
fit there in the field
what if they but it's identifying that
early in a from a form so I happen to
know to answer that that's because that
that is a different issue to what we've
got in front of here this is a temporary
event
I'll be honest with you I understand
your concerns about that but we are only
here to look at this in front of us
today and our concerns over child safety
and the averages have been bought
through the chair and one at a time okay
I just wanted to say as a mother of one
of the children it fits as well and I've
got lots of friends whose children's
have been two previous after parties not
necessarily at Nicki's but they've been
held for years and this is that I mean
as far as I'm aware aren't there have
never been any incidents or accidents or
any concerns over previous it's
literally just because a couple of moms
have reported this one that it's come to
light okay thank you for what you're
saying but we again we are only
interested in this particular hearing
can can ones on can you tell me the
parents are collecting the children from
the party what measures do you have in
place if a parent doesn't turn up for
their child
well I've got the I'll find their mums
mobile and then I'll ring their mums
mobile and I'll ask one of the other
mums if they can take them home as a
parent I would wanna go and pick my
child up wouldn't you so I'm hoping that
they all want to come and pick their
kids up as well
okay I've got another question here does
your mic on nice-nice come on down
that's fine just got questioned on the
insurance I'm looking for the paperwork
with partners for stables insurance have
you checked with you insurance so they
would cover this sort of activity late
at night in the dark and um they'll be a
little bit concerned about fire risk
weights various tables and you said it's
just one gate which someone would be on
the guy all the time making sure kids
don't get through cigarettes and stuff
like that is that how reasonable is that
how that works
you probably your front door and then
maybe maybe someone walking around the
state was making sure nobody's creep
back in
one more um we say you've got burger ban
their burger ban burger van there would
you'd like
would they be giving free water away and
stuff like that just in case they get
dehydrated the kids there is water and
stuff there like that sorry there is
quite a few questions right um
stewarding they have radio controls yes
so what is your plan of those radio
controls fail and trust me they do live
fail so how are they going to
communicate with each other in the event
of an emergency I thought you said it
was five acres
okay so just walk me through there's an
emergency and nonetheless are working
you need to evacuate the site what are
you going to do a handheld what make a
phone right and how are you going to
convey this to all the staff before no
no you need to have an actual evacuation
procedure in the event of everything
failure okay and again if the emergency
was down in the lower road perhaps
somebody's driven into your area from
outside to come and make it run amok at
your party so you do not want to take
them down the lane where's your
alternative evacuation point and that's
all written in your vent plan these are
children so I'm hoping that you're
starting to see where we're coming from
but you've got 100 children in your care
you will have as parents have gone and
running this event have gone through all
your emergency protocol of how you're
going to deal with an emergency so in an
ideal world your radio down you evacuate
them all down to your lower paddock okay
you can't get to the lower paddock so
you're going to take them somewhere else
where would you take them and this is it
you need to have a procedure of where
you will go if there is an event and you
need an ambulance or place to arrive
where would be their meeting point have
you provide provided there the main gate
and then they're being escorted up to
okay extreme weather conditions and we
all know Deventer some of those some
Boston fair and the tragedy there what
what how will you put out a message to
all of these people attending that it is
canceled
and has that been given out on the any
form that they've registered that in the
event of emergency you will be contacted
X amount of hours before but you've got
to go now back to three point two we
have no power to enforce these
conditions on there because they're not
in this life
okay
so how will you ensure there is no
alcohol and then if they've already had
alcohol what's your interpretation of
intoxicated what's your interpretation
of intoxicated I'll be honest with you
that could to be exact
sorry chairman Perrin that would be
exactly how would you know that that's
alcohol not drugs or a medical condition
pay they would come and tell me and how
will you manage the traffic coming in
now because there's going to be quite a
lot of traffic if there's a hundred cars
but if they're all turning up if they're
all turning up at the same time then
you're gonna have a lot of traffic in
one area
[Music]
says in your says here that if anybody
is intoxicated or what drugs you can
export them to somewhere where doesn't
that she say on the so you just how
would you control their behavior if they
are aggressive or under the influence of
anything
it concerns me that you mention they may
have bottles and they would have to come
to you to have the bottles open
Thank You chairman um I'm just going
back to the rendezvous point for a room
the emergency vehicles there is none on
your event plane and if the track is
only wide enough for one vehicle and so
you've gone emergency as those cars are
coming to pick them up even if you've
got four people in each car you're
looking at around 25 cars up and down
that Lane I've got huge concerns that an
emergency vehicle would not be able to
get out there we are talking an
emergency vehicle that has never been
and the way because come in the opposite
was where this is to be through the
chair so yes your question well actually
I'm gonna um if it's okay with officers
I want to myself the place around the
rendezvous point
yep I will let the place ask that
question sorry um
would you like to ask your questions
thank you Alex please just won't go and
your colleague said if the cars coming
down there's no way they can overtake
but if the wait their turn if there's a
problem
how'd you expect police officers remind
both fire ambulance and police vehicles
may be coming from miles away from
different locations don't use the police
or fire service for emergency service
and that location took they were just go
in a location on them that appears the
most direct route to the site and how
you can ensure that those vehicles that
can't be overtook can't be able to place
emergency vehicles
yes please
thank you
then I'll see my cousin we said the
area's very dark it's a narcotic ten
minutes in daylight to find your
premises and what's your expectation of
how the police or any service in the
dark they're gonna find the location
place yes that's all ten minutes for my
colleague on that road and they like to
find the actual premises
so would you be providing its excuse me
would you be providing signage to help
any emergency vehicles that may be
needed
[Music]
thank you does the officer have any more
questions I've got several if I might
please
and obviously the flyer suggests alcohol
consumption is can be tolerated and we
then had the righty from here sit when
we thought we could have alcohol that
was gonna be allowed narrow we can the
search people to stop it and can ask do
you actually know the cause of Licensing
Act and your health and safety
responsibilities because quite clearly
this evening it was going to take place
unlicensed do you've previously done
unlicensed events so what are you gonna
do to comply the objectives under
license neck to the regarding potential
harm from children and prevent in
alcohol sale alcohol supply to underage
children because it appears you don't
actually know what the law says and
that's what concerns us the most thank
you
I asked to
I think the police officer was asking
are you aware of the licensing laws and
providing it the the flyer that you
originally provided does give the
implication that there will be alcohol
thank you yeah could I ask how you've
informed the children and the parents
alcohol was no longer going to be
tolerated
[Music]
thank you
but the police officer continued yes you
said that all the children may our
children that can be searched at the
door hey many of the security staff are
you implying they've got enhanced DPS
checks to make sure the children are
unmolested chewing searches at princes
which DPS enhanced checked security
staff if he caught at the video place
[Music]
are you aware of distinction between
hearts DPS that requires a person to be
in some sort of safeguarding role to
apply for that enhanced DPS check and
which is different from the SI secured
industry check which even the DPS are
you aware of the difference and the
danger of young children being searched
by adults that haven't gotten hearts
deviate
it isn't a given to have enhanced I'm
sorry children I'm sorry chairman and
they are children right in the eye of
the law they are children make all them
young people but they're children and
therefore they go under the Child
Protection Act etc thank you
give him that there's an after-prom
party what is in your opinion the
attraction of anything that if it was an
event Fred I was going to free a club
would be likely to attract tourism why
is it you think there's a draw for
children toward even after prom prior to
come to this venue what realistically do
you think that draw is
sir have any more questions thank the
party finish is 11 there's no reason why
student can fall sick and trick you too
right mobile phone numbers the thing and
if they were not allowed to go to the
venue well I can just leave the
after-prom party early with their mates
will come to your party house
[Music]
thank you Thank You chairman
just on that pointers from the
representatives Nicky or your the area
of the premises
so that would be under your
responsibility under the Act of 1957 as
the owner of the land so if somebody has
it should a child forged a signature or
anything that will be your
responsibility so something happens and
this is what we're trying to put across
here now everybody wants children to
enjoy themselves have a good time it
needs to be in a safe environment where
we know that they're going to be safe
and there are the things that we're
discussing here
sorry um there is a quite a list and
your lighting how is it provided yep is
it emilich tricity or generator okay in
the event of that failing for any reason
you got backup words yeah
diesel petrol thank you do any of the
other authorities have any questions
that I would like to raise
okay
any party is able to make a short
closing statement not exceeding two
minutes the order of closing statements
will be the responsible authorities in
turn and then the applicants thank a
chair and DEF CON from Essex place again
um I don't think anyone's disputing the
goodwill of the parents of this event
however sometimes the laws there to
protect vulnerable people from such
matters and in this case I think it's
quite evident that young people need
protect him from the issues that could
materialize on the night um last year
Essex Police had over 6000 temporary
analysis we only objected to - it's very
small proportion of what we we object to
so you can see we treat this matter
quite seriously if it was an adult event
we would have concerns because of the
location and of a matter that you've
Illustrated today as is a child event we
have serious concerns and I know others
have shared their concerns in in this
Rome about that the fact they wouldn't
want their child to be at such an event
in such circumstances that's it from
Essex Police Thank You environment
health no further comments
do you have any two-minute closing
statement
thank you
the subcommittee will adjourn and the
hymn the hearing so that the
subcommittee may retire to consider the
decision we may request the presence of
a legal adviser to provide legal advice
thank you for waiting while we
deliberated over this the committee has
given careful consideration to the
application and all of the written and
verbal evidence presented including the
objection notices from Essex Police the
environmental health and the views of
the applicant Nicholas Smith supported
by two parents the committee notes that
the venue is not a licensed premises and
therefore no conditions can be attached
to a temporary event notice the
committee determines that the events to
be held on the 26 to the 28th of June
2019 namely and after prom parties
between the hours of 2300 and oh three
hundred for Parke Swain Parks and Fitz
why Mott school under the temporary
events notice would undermine the
licensing objectives for the following
reasons crime and disorder the flyer
originally distributed by the applicant
demonstrated an expectation that
children under the age of 18 would
consume alcohol and become intoxicated
whilst the applicant has now confirmed
that alcohol will not be allowed we are
not satisfied that without suitable
conditions this can be prevented the
organisers have stated that they will
cease drugs at the entrance but have not
adequately addressed how searches will
be undertaken and whilst we accept their
evidence that they intend to employ si a
in credit accredited door staff they
have no understanding of DBS certificate
requirements or knowledge that enhance
certificates would be required for the
search of children the committee is not
satisfied that the applicant can ensure
that effective searches will be
undertaken to prevent the circulation of
drugs alcohol and sharp objects at the
event whilst the applicant has now
clarified that any drug seed would be
stored in a secure metal box rather than
being burned we are not satisfied the
app can can ensure that the correct
procedures and
safekeeping can be guaranteed in
relation to seized alcohol drugs or
sharp objects at an event occurring in
an open space without licensing
conditions public nuisance evidence has
been provided that there is a likelihood
that this objective will be undermined
as the event is occurring outside in a
marquee
with no noise attenuation we accept that
the applicant has stated that she has
spoken with her neighbors but the
increased level of noise from the disco
is likely to cause disturbance within
sleeping hours to local residents Public
Safety the committee agrees with the
concerns raised by the police that the
parents dropping off collecting children
will increase vehicle movements where
drivers will be unfamiliar with the road
layout on a poor quality road thereby
increasing the risk of collision those
who walk the route will be at risk of
harm from fools or becoming
disorientated especially if intoxicated
and they are concerned about the access
to the venue by emergency vehicles we
are also concerned that the evacuation
procedures are not particularly detailed
or would be effectively controlled given
the remote location size of site as a
whole and the lack of light in
prevention of harm to children as
referenced above there is a risk of
exposure to drugs and alcohol as a
result of how the event have been
advertised the committee are not
satisfied that the applicant has
suitable knowledge of staff requirements
namely the enhanced DBS checks in order
to protect the welfare and physical
safety of children attend in the events
particularly for the purposes of search
in them or safeguarding them should they
fall ill the applicant relies on
contacting children's parents for
collection but has not been able to
satisfactorily demonstrate to this
committee that they can ensure that per
rental information has been properly
surprised supplied for these reasons the
committee has determined that a counter
notice should be served in order to
promote the objectives of prevention of
crime and disorder the prevention of
public nuisance Public Safety and the
protection of children from harm this
concludes the hearing thank you for
attending council notice will issue to
you by the licensing officers within the
next few days we are sympathetic to your
situation and suggest pursuit for future
applications it would be advisable to
seek guidance from the licensing team
thank you
[Music]